Kong: Skull Island is the second movie in
Legendary and Warner Bros' Godzilla and King
Kong MonsterVerse, and it features a cool
scene right at the end of all the credits
with some exciting teases for the Godzilla
sequel, King of the Monsters.
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video, I want to take a look at
what we can look forward to in Godzilla 2
based on the post-credits scene in Kong: Skull
Island and I'm also going to talk a bit about
Godzilla vs Kong.
If you haven't seen Kong: Skull Island yet,
there are spoilers ahead for that film plus
the Godzilla movies and Kong movies.
To avoid those, click here for my spoiler-free
video of the movie and venture back here after
you've had a chance to see it!
OK, then, let's get stuck in: After all the
credits have rolled, we see Tom Hiddleston
and Brie Larson, stuck in an interrogation
room by themselves.
They seem to be talking to some mysterious
unseen figures behind a two-way mirror and
they agree to pretend that Skull Island never
existed and they never went there.
Corey Hawkins and Tian Jing then walk in and
welcome Hiddleston and Larson to Monarch,
an organisation that covertly studies monsters
like Godzilla.
The two Monarch staff then explain to Hiddleston
and Larson that Skull Island is just the beginning
and that there are more monsters out there.
They warn that the world never belonged to
humans, instead it belonged to the monsters,
and that the question is how long it will
be before the monsters take it back.
Hawkins then reveals that "Kong is not the
only King" and shows a set of files Monarch
has on other monsters.
This is when we get to see some cave paintings
of Godzilla and three iconic kaiju; Rodan,
Mothra and King Ghidorah.
The final drawing shows Godzilla fighting
the three-headed monster Ghidorah and, as
the screen fades to black, we hear the iconic
Godzilla roar.
OK, let's look in more detail at this post-credits
scene and what it means for the new MonsterVerse.
Rodan is a type of pteranodon that first appeared
on the big screen in Toho Studios' 1956 movie
Rodan, and was initially a foe of Godzilla's
in the 1964 movie "Ghidorah: The Three-Headed
Monster".
Mothra, as the name suggests, is a moth-like
creature that has often been portrayed as
a saviour.
She's one of movie studio Toho's most popular
kaiju and is surpassed only by Godzilla in
the number of movies that she's appeared in.
She went up against Godzilla in the 1964 movie
Mothra vs Godzilla and also in 1992's Godzilla
vs Mothra, so it's quite possible we'll see
her as an antagonist to Godzilla, at least
to start with, in Godzilla 2.
By the way, the 2014 Godzilla movie included
a couple of Mothra easter eggs that already
teased the iconic kaiju.
Mothra's name appeared on some labels stuck
together on an old dilapidated tank at Joe
and Ford's former home.
And there was a very heavy butterfly and moth
theme going on in Ford's class the day the
nuclear plant went down.
The paintings of a dragon-like creature in
the end credits are representations of King
Ghidorah.
Ghidorah was a powerful enemy of Godzilla,
Mothra and Rodan when he first appeared in
Ghidorah: The Three-Headed Monster.
The idea for Ghidorah's multiple heads was
inspired by a Japanese mythological eight-headed
creature.
In the 1964 Toho movie, the monstrous dragon
is an extra-terrestrial being that hatches
from an egg which initially appeared to be
a meteor.
Ghidorah attempts to take over the Earth until
Mothra stands up to him, with Godzilla and
Rodan eventually deciding to team up with
her to defeat Ghidorah and send him back to
space.
Other appearances of Ghidorah in Toho's movies
have him under the control of aliens or time-travellers,
and there's one incarnation of him in which
he's a heroic guardian monster that protected
Japan.
By the way, the 2014 Godzilla movie included
a little easter egg to Ghidorah via a submerged
dragon head where the female MUTO had laid
her eggs in San Francisco.
It'll be interesting to see how the Godzilla:
King of the Monsters movie combines Godzilla,
Rodan and Mothra with King Ghidorah and whether
it'll follow a similar path to the 1964 film
where they're against each other to begin
with, until they decide to combine forces
to fight the bigger threat of King Ghidorah.
Kong: Skull Island also sets us up for the
hopefully epic movie Godzilla vs Kong.
In Skull Island we meet an adolescent Kong
who is already an impressive 100 foot tall,
but, at this size he would be very hard pressed
to go up against Godzilla who is 350 foot
tall.
However, during Skull Island, John C Reilly's
character Marlow mentions that Kong is still
growing and, as the film is set in 1973, that
means that Kong still has over 40 years of
growth ahead of him before he meets Godzilla
in 2020.
By the way, this won't be the first time that
Kong and Godzilla have done battle on the
big screen; that was in the 1962 Japanese
movie King Kong vs Godzilla, which featured
Kong getting stronger by absorbing electricity
from various sources and appeared to end somewhat
inconclusively with the pair falling into
the Ocean during a fight after which we only
see Kong re-emerge though the film's characters
speculated that Godzilla survived.
Still, according to Toho, Kong was victorious.
And given that both Godzilla and Kong are
anti-heroes, I imagine that at some point
they may still put their differences aside,
at least temporarily, to fight a potentially
even bigger foe.
So, how hyped are you now for Godzilla 2:
King of the Monsters and Godzilla vs Kong?
Do you think Godzilla will team up with Mothra
and Rodan to battle King Ghidorah?
And who do think would win a fight between
Godzilla and Kong?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments
below.
If you enjoyed this, hit that like button
and why not subscribe for more reviews, easter
egg videos and cool movie facts?!
You can also tap or click the screen here
to watch more videos you might like.
Thanks for watching and see you next time!
Yippee ki-yay movie lovers!